[Musik]
das
die super milde schutz person und
verletzte
klartext zweitägiger den rücken
[Musik]
gesichert nehmen er verschoben habe
internet genau was stück weiter vorgehen
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bitte hören dass ihre da gibt es kein
zögern da gibt es kein zaudern und shoot
bin ich in sicherheit hier in der maria
theresien kaserne in wien übrigens
herzlich willkommen schauen wir mal an
was die militärpolizei so alles drauf
hat und ich sehr gut da schon ein
kommandant robert herrmann beim kommando
militärs treffen mit der polizei gesagt
weil wir schauen uns jetzt einfach an
welche fähigkeiten unsere leute lernen
ist schauen wir so gerne gemacht hätte
[Musik]
die kameraden was du ja schon
kennengelernt das ist ein zugriffs
informiert sie sind ausgestattet und
ausgerüstet um einen straftäter
festzunehmen dazu sind meine damen und
herren dann entsprechend mit
schutzausrüstung ausgestattet hellen
gehörschutz google schutzweste und
zusätzlich verwenden wir neben unserer
standardausrüstung der sturmgewehr
lästige 77 1 mb
das ist hier zwei grad maschinen und da
hinten einer unseren streifen golf der
große unterschied von uns zu manch
anderem verband ist dass wir ein
einsatzverband sind der laufend auch im
inland aufgaben zu erfüllen hat so wie
diese beiden trotz die jetzt hinaus
fahren um zb bei veranstaltungen die
gruppe entsprechend zu schützen
[Musik]
wir haben es einige spezialisierung
gesehen die wir so im verband haben ich
glaube wir haben es heute genug geredet
es geht zur selbstverteidigung für dich
ja wird wirst du mit unseren damen und
herren gemeinsam schauen wir also mehr
an die nazis hier
[Musik]
[Applaus]
halo ist ja was die hörwahrnehmung zwang
selbstverteidigung wenn du willst das
ist bei kursbeginn aber ob ich nicht
mitmachen ich gehe mal mit der oder noch
jetzt hier messer abwehr ja eine sehr
einfache abwehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zwecks einmal vor dem schlag das mahnmal
noch das was demnächst wirklich nicht
immer machen ist eine zukunftstechnik
[Musik]
darauf mit der rechten hand die tiere
hier seinen ellbogen und drehe einfach
jetzt zu boden
dann gehe ich mit meinem linken bein in
die schulter ist ein kleines abgeführt
ja genau liegt das kleine der schulter
recht dass beim aufstellen
das rechte bein nach vorne stehen über
eine ausstellung
[Musik]
jetzt geht's los was auch robert moran
situations training war recht gut gehen
wir dann erst richtig an
[Musik]
perfekter absolut sicher personenschutz
die profis von der militärpolizei
die haben das natürlich drauf das
bedeutet auch autofahren und zwar
richtig gut auto fahren
die haben zwei autos ein blaues da ist
die zu schützende person drinnen und ein
graues ebenfalls mit personenschützern
gefüllt da vorne tun jetzt so als würde
die fahrten gleich beginnt um die ecke
von außen ist schon ziemlich
beeindruckend aber von innen wird das
ist ein richtiger spaß so mit hallo
okay du bist mir noch mehr fragen alex
langsam wieder beginnen zwischen wänden
jetzt gab es eine kleine kleine einigen
[Musik]
ich nehme an diese zuschauer ringe
hinter glas diesem bereich genau aber
nicht auf die bitten da nach oben zu
gehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das selbstverteidigungskurs das haben
wir auch besser drauf als ich und sie
können zum beispiel einen tatort
forensisch zu untersuchen das ganze auch
gerichtlich verwertbar ist also
polizeiliche aufgaben übernehmen und das
zum beispiel im ausland wenn irgendwo
ein neuer staat entsteht eine neue
demokratie und nie gefährdet versorgen
muss dass die dort so sicher leben
können wie wir das schon die längste
zeit hier gewohnt in österreich das
machen die soldatinnen soldaten bei der
militärpolizei
ich bin jetzt zum ersten mal begegnet
vor zwei jahren gut vor vielen jahren
als wachsoldat aber nicht ich
kennengelernt habe sie erst jetzt und
das war echt cool du hast dich
geschlagen
frage sehen und ich darf dir deswegen
den patch der militärpolizei und
militärstreife überreichen
eine besondere freude die ich zu unserem
hilfen militärpolizisten zu ernennen
und dann habe ich noch eine kleine
überraschung für dich
nachdem du dich so tapfer geschlagen
hast der dich der einen kleinen tempi
robert überreichen
ja und ich versuchen noch nie so weiter
zu trainieren dankeschön mit bart wird
[Musik]
ich glaube das betrifft ich der
entertainer sind unterwegs in
[Musik]